1.9 trillion dollars relief so far
i wrote the bill on the environment
pay them more what f is
just i i i don't know what to say about
this anymore other than joe biden
is he's a crazy person guys he's a crazy
person he's
adult he's not with us he's crazy
there's a reason why you don't see clips
regularly of joe biden being played in
the media instead they'll sort of print
what he says right you see it in the
print
but you'll never see these clips
circulating anywhere but sort of oppo
sources right you'll see it you'll hear
it on my show you'll see it on fox news
you're never going to see this clip of
joe biden blasted out
i mean this is a live press conference
so they sort of got it but you're not
gonna see it repeated
okay so this is a live press conference
yesterday at the white house
and uh and here's the president of the
united states
being like this is so weird he's just a
weird old dude man i mean like this is
all right here we go i got them
1.9 trillion dollars relief so far
they're going to be getting checks in
the mail that are consequential
this week i wrote the bill
on the environment pay them more
this is an employee's
employee's bargaining chip now
what's happening um okay put aside what
he's saying which is
insanely stupid right but i mean what
he's actually saying
there is that if you want people to come
back to work you have to pay them more
because the government is paying them to
stay home and somehow this is good for
the economy
and then he says inflation is not the
predictable result which is stupid okay
so put aside the content
why is he channeling the clown from it i
just don't understand
why because he's not with us gang
because he's a weird
old man he's like georgie
would you like your boat back it's worth
1.9 trillion dollar
pay your employees more georgie come
down and here's a balloon
i'll be honest that's like if you have
nightmares at night about monsters
hiding under your bed
that's the voice right there that that's
what's going on
okay and then he just says like adult
things all the time
he just says adult things all the time
so he he was asked
so he he finishes a press conference
yesterday and there's this horrifying
situation
in surf side florida and and our prayers
go out
to the the folks over in surf side
there's been this this
horrifying condo collapse in in
surf side like half the building
collapsed it appears
likely that there were structural
defects in the building that were
revealed over time as maybe the building
was sinking into the ground because
it was built on the beach very scary
stuff 100 people missing
really tragic and and by the way just
going to put this out there for for
folks who do want to give
there is a there is a website that has
been set up
by one of the big synagogues over there
where you can give money to help out the
families of the
of the people who are suffering uh it's
at uh i'll give you the website it's at
the hessedfund.com
v c h e s e d f u n dot com
slash h u l
o f b a l h a r b o u r slash miami
tragedy and it's a long web address
but uh they're trying to raise like a
million bucks for for the people who
are suffering from that strategy in any
case joe biden finishes his press
conference yesterday
and he just um starts wandering out of
the room
and kamala harris has to remind him that
this thing happened and he's just like
oh my gosh
it's so awkward here we go
will you travel to florida sir can we
ask you about florida what you've
learned and what oh
yes i apologize yes thank you my
president
okay and he just starts laughing at
himself or forget it's just it's so
awkward to watch he's still
my president right he's your president
too it's it's um it is awkward to watch
he also said yesterday that if he had
his way there would be no private
contributions to campaigns at all
all campaigns would be publicly funded
what in the act
what what okay here we go
there's a lot of ancillary pieces of
this legislation i strongly support
i strongly support the idea that there's
no there's no uh
provide my way there'd be no private
contributions to see who gets elected
uh how much money you raise no private
contributions
to political candidates okay what are
you talking about there is the supposed
voting rights bill that sets up
public funding for candidates so your
taxpayer dollars should go to joe biden
to run for office this is what he would
prefer that's good
also he's been using the term latinx
which is a good indicator that you've
never met a latino or latina person
because there's not a single latino
person on planet earth calls themselves
latinx it's only a bunch of upper crust
white idiots
who took critical race theory studies
who who think that latinx is an actual
term
that is used by the way you know the
origin of latinx right
latin x is because is because spanish is
a gendered language
okay and latino is for males and latinas
for females and so we wouldn't want to
say latino
because we wouldn't want to say latinos
because that inevitably
includes women what so instead they set
up
x that's the stupidest thing i've ever
heard it's unbelievably dumb
okay hebrew is also a gendered language
right when you say for example people
the word in hebrew for for people is an
ashim
okay the the suffix in english would be
why m but it's ud mem
the suffix eem is for males but it
includes females
just as when in english you say human it
includes the word man and now woman
and when you say mankind includes man
but it includes women
so now we are going to do this with
foreign languages this is the stupidest
thing i've
he here he is being an idiot
there's a reason why it's been harder to
get african-americans
initially to get vaccinated because
they're used to being experimented on
the tuskegee airmen and others
people have memories people have long
memories
it's awful hard as well to get
latinx vaccinated as well why
they're worried that they'll be
vaccinated and deported
that um what okay so first of all what
he's saying there
right there is that the um the
um what he is saying there is like
racist
right he's saying that the reason that
the latino people are not getting
vaccinated is because they're all afraid
they're going to get supported
now 18 of the american population is
latino
i'm fairly certain the vast majority of
those people are not illegal immigrants
are not afraid of being deported so
no on that and also i failed to
understand how it is good logic
that because between 1932 and 1972
there were tuskegee experiments racist
experiments that were conducted
that allowed essentially the the
syphilis to grow in black people to see
how
it was going to affect their minds i
failed to see how an experiment that was
first conducted
in 1932 is a good excuse for not getting
a vaccine in 2021
nonetheless the um it's
it's weird it's it's a weird thing also
i like how he calls it
the tuskegee airmen experiment uh no
that no those are two separate things
those are two separate things okay the
tuskegee experiment
was a cruel and vicious racist policy
tuskegee airmen were the black men who
flew
in jet fighters who flew in fighters
during
world war ii not the same thing he's not
with us
meanwhile he had kamala harris waiting
in the wings which is not
if you thought that it was creepy when
joe biden was whispering at you just a
few moments ago
how creepy is it what was going on in
the background of this
particular bipartisan photo so yeah joe
biden
kristen cinema by the way i just have to
compliment kristen cinema's
sense of style like it actually is kind
of fabulous
i am not a i'm not a fashion a fashion
reviewer
although i will say that i found it very
odd and still find it odd that nancy
pelosi has a face mask to match every
outfit but kristen cinema really brings
it right i mean like
that's pretty cool outfit i kind of like
that is a kristen cinema uh
shows up wearing like this this red
thing and it's it's cool okay and you've
got this entire bipartisan group of
senators
and then lurking in the background
there's something happening behind mitt
romney's shoulder
there's a white pillar and then behind
that pillar in front of the white house
someone is waiting someone
is watching
my god
[Music]
oh man uh ain't that just a metaphor for
what's happening in the country right
now
kamala harris just waiting off to the
side waiting waiting
hmm man worst job in america joe biden's
food taster
do not walk down a set of stairs with uh
with kamala harris if you are joe biden
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video